when people socialize with the wrong
crowd bad things can happen
they may form questionable values and
develop poor attitudes toward law and
order
and if their friends are criminals they
naturally learn from them and over time
adopt their way of life psychologically
this process is known as differential
association
[Music]
differential association theory is the
work of edwin sutherland who spent his
life studying principles of criminology
and found nine distinct precepts
to learn how this works in real life
let's see how robin a shy 14 year old
boy ends up in jail
criminal behavior is learned robin
learns it after meeting a new friend
it is learned through interaction and
conversation with others often supported
by storytelling
[Laughter]
this learning process takes place
primarily in small and intimate groups
books video games and mass media have
little impact
the learning of criminal behavior
includes sharing insights and techniques
as well as reasons and attitudes that
favor criminal actions
motives are learned by dividing the
legal system into good laws and bad laws
robin learns that the laws protecting
poor people's property are good while
the laws protecting rich people's
property are bad
we become delinquent once our rationale
for breaking the law outweighs our
rationale for respecting it robin steals
once he believes that he needs to take
from the rich to give to the poor
our learning experiences vary in
frequency duration the priority we give
them and how intense they are robin's
time as a criminal is over when he and
his friends all get arrested
learning criminal behavior is like
learning anything else
robin learns this just like his sister
learns math the same mechanisms are
involved
[Music]
although criminal behavior is an
expression of one's needs and values it
is not explained by them
non-criminal behavior can also stem from
the exact same needs and values
edwin sutherland was an american
sociologist whose work had a big impact
on criminal policy his theory recognizes
that criminal attitudes can be learned
socially consequently they can also be
unlearned in other words sutherland
helped us understand that kids like
robin can be rehabilitated
what do you think how can we help keep
society free from crimes that happen on
the street and in the top floors of big
corporations
and if sutherland was right is jail the
right place for young offenders
please share your thoughts in the
comments below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education
visit our patreon that's patreon.com
sprouts